uh one time
very very tense moment yeah i just i
just won the hundred meters and
immediately after they were like let's
do the 200 meters they didn't think
let's space it out
right so i was actually naked yeah and i
was lining up for the 200 meters and i
really really really wanted to win i
wanted this more than like any i don't
know why i was so ultra competitive this
is like the olympics for me yeah i need
this
i was so goddamn nervous that like i was
like what is this i felt like a little
little drizzle go down my leg
right i was so nervous that like i for
like a brief moment repeat myself like
0.1 seconds and i was like stop it's
like a little bit yeah it was like a
little beep and i was like
that's never happened before what was
that
[ __ ]
luckily i but you know i didn't i didn't
give a [ __ ] that i peed myself but i
already was like no one else saw that
right
but luckily i was so sweaty from the
previous event still that nobody thought
that i'd pissed you just like shake it
off
just shake your leg
just like let's get back to it boys
i i went to it and then yeah i won but i
really needed the piss after it
my bladder it was have you ever been
that nervous your bladder is completely
opened
yeah i've i've had that before brother
that happened
trust me i've never been i didn't know
that could happen yeah
i've i've done the little like loop
before oh my god
i had that before like a really
important like piano competition
but but at least but like the the
problem was i had it a lot worse than
you probably were like because i was
wearing a suit
oh no
yeah
i was like in a well-air-conditioned
room like long pants like in a suit
with like all these like really properly
dressed like asian kids next to me i'm
just like oh [ __ ]
did you see it could you see the pair
well luckily not but my god it was it
was hard to use the pedal while my leg
was also a little bit wet
i was like oh god
how did the stream get down did it go
all the way uh like almost to my knee oh
my god that's that way they missed this
[ __ ] scene in your life in your line
in april
when they're [ __ ] waiting
i love the chapter where corset pisses
himself
when you're a kid you get anxious
exactly i i also used to try it i felt
really bad for the kid who had to follow
after oh
because i'm like i didn't i didn't check
but i was like i'm sorry if the seat is
a little there's a wet pad there's a
weird patch on that seat right
i [ __ ] nailed the competition though
so worth it in the end but
did you win the 200 meters i did i did
and i was also
so competitive
uh to the point where i don't know if i
can do this now but when i was a kid
when i was running and i thought like oh
i really need to stop i just wouldn't
stop and i would always end up throwing
up when i stopped when i saw you you
were that kid you were the kid who just
threw up everywhere or always because
right to me it was like i was like no i
i need to win like i have to win
so like if there was a like like i'm at
the last stretch i still got a little
left in me and i'm like i can't stop now
i need to throw up so
so one one year um this is again so i i
was doing like six events
and i've won the hundred i'd won the 200
and again right after it what comes
after the 200 it's the 400 yeah because
it's kind of like the same thing yeah
you sprint at the end you kind of run
fast at the same time why would they not
split it up like they were it was it was
just because because at our school they
split it off yeah i think i think they
might have assumed that uh different
people would be doing different effects
i think they assumed people would do
different things yeah yeah i would get
max like two minutes break yeah so i was
doing the 400 right and i was already
like before i even started this race i
remember i was like
like because i was already still naked
from the other one and i was like how
the [ __ ] am i gonna win this one yeah
and so i'm i'm in this race right i'm i
get to the 200 meter mark right this is
where you're like the on switch has to
come off yeah start sprinting yeah
because like i'm i'm like kind of like
i'm in the middle i'm not really in i'm
kind of i got a lot of ground to make up
because i was going a little too slow
yeah so i just start going crazy man i
get like to 50 meters and i'm like oh no
on the side on the side of the racetrack
right luckily it's a grass racetrack so
yeah that's just extra compost yeah and
i luckily i was not i was not in the
middle
oh i was i was on the i was in the first
lane so i just i'm like 50 meters into
this sprint i'm going all out and i just
have to i just
and it became uh i became a bit of a
laughingstock for the rest of that that
would have been amazing to see
i was literally just like powering
through like a machine and then just had
to just start vomiting it was awful oh
my god because i just didn't know my
limits as a kid i just didn't i just
didn't like yeah my willpower was just
beyond my body's ability apparently but
it happened all the time during long
distances while i always threw up
well like i i sucked at long distance i
think mostly most mostly because i have
asthma so i could only do like 200
meters at most before like my asthma
would like start to kick in yeah yeah
yeah it was rough man long distance is
horrible yeah yeah it is because it was
really muddy and freezing it was always
during winter did you do yeah yeah yeah
yeah you gotta be a real masochist to
enjoy long run like long running like
it's like why would you especially
people who do it for like club
activities and stuff it's like what do
you do after school i lo i run yeah yeah
why
because so did they make all the kids do
it when you did it yeah no no so like if
kids so basically kids could opt in and
out at our school are you knocked
every kid needed to do an activity yeah
you know you know you didn't have to do
like a certain like you know a certain
amount but you needed to do at least one
oh no no no no
there were some years where i was just
like i don't want to do anything today
dude for my school it was like on this
day we're doing we're doing two
kilometers you have to do the two
kilometers oh [ __ ] that you have no
choice we had we had other events for
that kind of stuff where like kids are
you talking about pe or sports day p
okay no if it's pe then yeah if we're
doing activity
sorry yeah if if if it's pe even if it's
pv
uh you have to do the actually yeah
because i remember that like they would
like get really angry at the kids that
were just like walking
[Music]
like so because like we had at our
school we had like i think like four
different sports days or like four days
yeah
yeah
so we had the we had the traffic winter
olympics in australia yeah no so we had
like a track and field day yeah and then
we also had like a what we called the
swimming carnival which was we went to
like a local swimming pool
and we would do like swimming like
every kid looked forward to it because
it was just basically a day off from
school where you just do fun stuff and
then and then yeah you could sit on the
grass if you didn't give a [ __ ] and then
yeah and then we had another sports day
uh where we did it on the beach
so we did like you know like beach flags
and like uh you know like you'd like
races like thousand meter races on the
beach and stuff like that like surfing
events and stuff like that and that was
just like another day where like if kids
didn't want to do it the kids didn't
have to do it and then we had a fourth
one during the winter and this was the
worst one it was called they don't have
it anymore but uh it was called the
walkathon
and walker yeah so it's think of like a
marathon right which is like 42 point
something kilometers yeah it's that but
you can walk it if you want so basically
it was it was basically we start from
the school you'd walk 20 kilometers
across like seven or eight beaches
because that was like the area we lived
in right and then you'd turn around and
you walk all the way back to the school
and you'd have to do that during the day
what and uh and i think they got rid of
it because
some
because i think some of like the higher
grade kids were just like calling ubers
i would [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that yeah
because like you because like when you
when you reach like the halfway point
you get like a sticker like put on your
like wrist so like that's how you know
when you came back to the school that
you made it to the halfway point so it's
like that was their like foolproof way
of making sure you did the whole thing
speed runners would be like i found it
yeah i found a clip yeah it's like i
come on a cloud
glitch
so what the senior kids would do is that
like they'd walk away from you know
they'd do a maybe like the first
kilometer yeah they'd like walk into a
street calling over get them to drive to
like a kilometer away from the halfway
point and they just like come out being
like oh hey i made it
and then they do it again
and uh but but i think they got rid of
it because uh like kids were cheating
but it was also like a charity event for
the school right so like you had to like
you know you had to pay like i think it
was like a dollar per student or
whatever for like pages to walk 42 pay
to walk 42 kilometers i mean for some
kids it was like oh [ __ ] yeah we just
have to walk today don't have to do
class
yeah i'll take that